Pardon, je me lève juste 2secondes.
Je sais, Clémence, qu'on est hyper harcant.
J'ai juste 1 message à faire passer à cette salle,
mais plus loin.
Je répète encore 1 fois,
je ne suis pas la voix des quartiers populaires,
mais je vais quand-même m'adresser à ma famille,
à mes amis, à mes collègues,
à tous ceux, à toutes celles et ceux qui souffrent des
conditions qu'on nous fait dans ce pays,
dans cette Europe.
Je leur dis que le neuf/06,
la dignité, le respect,
l'égalité, ça s'attire,
ça se confiere
avec 1 arme démocratique qui est celle du vote.
Donc allez voter,
pas d'excuses, pas d'arrangement.
Le neuf/06, allez tous voter pour la
la liste d'une heure populaire
et donnez-la, donnez-nous la force de tout changer.
Merci, merci Mohamed